i've spent a lot of time over the
weekend um thinking about what to say if
i got called today
or indeed whether to say anything at all
because i didn't know david personally
it's been a traumatic few days for many
people
none more so than david's family and
friends and it's there who remain at the
forefront of my mind this afternoon
but sadly i know from my own all too
similar experience
that in reality there is nothing anyone
can say to make things all right for
them
but nor is it any use to stay silent
so i welcome this opportunity to pay
tribute to someone who is clearly a well
respected and much loved colleague to
many people in this place
for reasons that i would never wish on
any other member of this house or indeed
anyone
i do have a unique perspective on what
those closest to david are going through
and i want to send them my love support
and solidarity
from myself my parents our family and
the people of bali and spain
i blocked out much of what happened when
joe was murdered
but i remember very clearly the moment i
took the phone call saying she had been
attacked
i remember physically trembling
and the visceral pain that overtook me
and it breaks my heart to think that
another family has had to experience
that phone call
and the nightmare which follows
is a rollercoaster of deep trauma that
no one should have to experience
i also know that david's family will
still be in utter shock
as i know many of you are
but i hope at some point they are able
to hear at least some of the beautiful
and very funny tributes that have been
paid to him today
and that that will provide a mortal of
comfort amidst their pain
i can't talk about david on a personal
level as i say i didn't know him
but from what i've heard he strikes me
as the sort of mp who i may well have
come across in the coming months and
ended up going for a couple with him
to hear his thoughts on the work he was
doing on the children's parliament or
animal welfare or getting more support
for people with learning disabilities
we would have been two back bench mps
from different parties and different
parts of the country discussing issues
close to our hearts
and i imagine it would have been a lot
of fun
but sadly that day will never come
i know that wider discussions will now
take place about the safety of mps
the awful abuse and intimidation we face
the nature of political discourse
and how we can deal with the evils of
terrorism
and it's quite right that they do
but today is about david and his family
along with his staff
colleagues and the community he served
so well
the service he gave
and the support we should show all of
them in the coming days weeks and months
it is up to us to make sure that we do
because i know more than most that they
will need it
and the powerful difference it will make
to them